[Music]
if you look at history political parties
your republican party's founded in 1854
in Wisconsin and it's founded by a bunch
of people that were exiled from other
parties which were mostly short-lived
parties it's founded by both women and
men it's the first political party that
is founded by women as well as by men
and it's founded as the party of reform
because they're a bunch of people that
they just think the other political
parties are not actually reforming
American politics as fast as they ought
to and chiefly what they mean by that is
ending slavery and coming up with a new
form of national unity to replace the
brokenness of the American political
arrangement under the country that's
divided half-slave and half-free as
people would have described it at the
time so it's a pretty significantly
important vision that what the party is
going to do is take the religious energy
of abolition which was a movement of
Christian evangelicals who believe that
all people under God are equal men and
women black and white and that slavery
had to be ended immediately and without
compensation to slave owners to take
that evangelical seal but instead of
asking people to do that work outside of
electoral politics to say we're going to
do this using the tools of party
politics we're going to form a party
that can achieve these ends it does a
pretty substantial moral commitment and
a commitment to instituting change using
a really important set of political
institutions mainly the party system but
also newspapers to say and so when
people say today the Republican Party
the party of Lincoln that's what they
mean well you would say the Republican
Party has reinvented itself many many
times it's like Odysseus's ship at this
point like what does this republican
party have to do with that republican
party it would be a really interesting
question
similarly the Democratic Party you could
tell completely Zig zaggy story about
the history of the Democratic Party one
of the reasons that the party system
isn't especially inspiring and I don't
think either party is especially
inspiring as an example of an enduring
institution is that both of them are
pretty willing to trade their
constituencies out for short-term gain
and you can see I think if you were to
do case studies you can see where
nonprofits and for-profit businesses
fall apart in that same way thinking
very much in the short-term about an
immediate you know market gain say or
dividends for their stockholders some
particular new dealer acquisition or
sell-off and they've actually dismantled
the whole intention of the of the
institution in the first place so the
Republican Party I don't mean to pick on
the Republican Party because you could
do the same dismantling of the
Democratic Party but the Republican
Party is for almost all of its history
the party of women it is as I said
founded by women it's the first party to
support suffrage it is the first party
to support equal rights and the
Republican Party in the 1970s under
Ronald Reagan says let's just give up on
the women because we could get these
white men and it'll be better for us and
this is just a deep abdication of the
long deep tradition of a commitment to I
won't say that the Republican Party
delivered suffered your equal white
rights because they really didn't women
had to do that work outside the
Republican Party but that continuous
support means that the party is I think
quite quite in a pickle terms of
understanding itself and its
relationship to its own past because it
for various reasons of immediate
political expediency has forgotten its
own past
[Music]